reden wir mal über die Kita Krise und
falls Sie jetzt denken h was soll das
denn für eine Krise sein weil bei ihnen
gar keine Kleinkinder wohnen erstens
herzlichen Glückwunsch zweitens hier mal
zum reinkommen der Sound eines Kindes
das zu Hause aufbewahrt wird weil die
Kita zu
hat
na nervt total ne halt die
Fresse sorry tatsächlich erleben wir
gerade eine Art volkitastrophe das ist
nicht übertrieben es ist nicht
übertrieben sechs von zehn deutschen
Eltern sagen dass ihre Kita in diesem
Jahr schon geschlossen oder nur noch
verkürzt geöffnet war viele andere
finden gar keinen kitaapatz für Ihr Kind
und das im Jubiläumsjahr ja wir feiern
nämlich 10 Jahre Rechtsanspruch auf
kitaitapatz
hurra den Rechtsanspruch auf dem
Kindergartenplatz den sie gewähren
müssen im Prinzip können sich die Leute
das in die Haare schmieren oder wie
sehen Sie das
ja ist das ulkig genau das war gerade
die Frage bei be Günther Jauch kann man
sich den Rechtsanspruch auf kitaapatz a
von der Backe putzen B durchs Klo spülen
C gepflegt hinten reinschieben oder D in
die Haare schmieren so und das irre ist
alle Antworten sind richtig meine Damen
und Herren ja war aber auch nur die 50 €
Frage so über die Hälfte der Eltern
stand dieses Jahr also bereits vor
geschlossenen kitaitatüren rund ein
Drittel hat deswegen die eigene
Berufstätigkeit reduziert verstehen sie
Eltern müssen bei uns arbeiten und dann
jammert man über Fachkräftemangel zumal
im Winter ja alles noch schlimmer wird
wegen der erkältungsfälle lauter Kranke
Erzieherinen klar nur weil auch die
Hälfte der Kinder krank sind und fehlen
kann die Kita St Johann Baptist heute
die gewohnten Öffnungszeiten überhaupt
anbieten siehst du so hat doch alles
sein gutes nachzulesen in dem berühmten
Kinderbuch Conny steckt die ganze Kita
an weil Mama arbeiten
muss sind bei uns genau wie Schulen
Ländersache also eine Art
geburtslotterie je nachdem wo man von
seiner Mutter rausgequetscht wird die
Linkspartei fordert diese Woche im
Bundestag viel mehr Engagement des
Bundes am besten ein Kita Sondervermögen
denn so wie jetzt kann es ja nicht
weitergehen es ist ein Teufelskreis zu
wenig Erzieherin und Erzieher heißt noch
mehr Stress für die paar vorhandenen
gleich mehr Krankheit und Burnout im
Kino läuft jetzt endlich mal ein
realistischer Mary Poppins Film da kommt
das legendäre Kindermädchen zu einer
deutschen Kita geflogen guckt mal ganz
kurz durchs Fenster und fliegt direkt
wieder nach Hause das alles in Mary
Poppins passt jetzt Kinder und arbeitet
lieber bei
leferando lieber bei leferando
verständlich so da haben wir doch seit
Januar das sogenannte Kita
qualitätsgesetz und davor gab's sie
erinnern sich bestimmt das Gute Kita
Gesetz muss ja gut sein denkt man
tatsächlich ist aber die
Personalsituation in den Kitas seitdem
schlechter geworden ja man sollte es
also umbenennen in schöne Idee Scheiße
umgesetzt gesetetzt die Länder aber auch
der Bund mit Familienministerin Lisa
Paus müssen sich noch viel mehr
reinhängen ja auch finanziell natürlich
frühkindliche Förderung ist so wichtig
sonst darf man sich später nicht wundern
über die vielen Jugendlichen die ohne
jeden Abschluss durch unser
Bildungssystem Rauschen kitakrise ein
überraschendes weil völlig neues Problem
nur ein Teil der Bewerber hat das Glück
überhaupt einen Platz zu bekommen und ob
die sich glücklich nennen können die
sich in den oft überalterten und
überbesetzten Kindergärten drängen darf
man
bezweifeln ja damals hat der WDR noch
mit Xylophon
gearbeitet ist heute zum Glück illegal
so im Kern braucht Kita Personal
natürlich mehr Gehalt mehr Anerkennung
und mehr Aufstiegschancen es gibt immer
noch Azubis die da gar kein Geld kriegen
und übrigens wenn alle kitaapätze nach
kindgerechten betreuungs besetzt würden
bräuchte es Achtung
308000 zusätzliche Stellen
a Kinder wie schön war das doch zu
Zeiten der Gebrüder Grimm oder als man
die überzähligigen Blagen einfach im
Wald aussetzen durfte
ja und irgendeine Hexe hat sich
gekümmert wunderbar so immerhin suchen
heute viele Kommunen neue Auszubildende
wenigstens das machen sie und trotzdem
wird gemeckert Stellen ausschreiben für
Ausbildungsstellen das ist in D Jahren
sind die fertig da ist meine Tochter in
der Schule ich habe jetzt das Problem ja
und das passt doch super erst in 3
Jahren denn ab 2026 gibt's ja auch den
Rechtsanspruch auf Ganztagsbetreuung in
der Schule ne und den kann sie sich dann
auch wer weiß es richtig in die Haare
schmieren meine Damen und her wegen der
langen Kita Wartelisten muss man sein
Kind heutzutage eigentlich schon während
der Zeugung anmelden ne und es kann
trotzdem dauern umso schöner wenn es
dann endlich klappt wie bei diesem Mann
der hier nach nur 70 Jahren erfährt dass
er einen Platz in der iltisgruppe kriegt
und sie freut sich weil er bald weniger
zu Hause ist in Sachen Kitas ist also
weiter viel Geduld gefragt gute Nerven
und Zähne zusammenbeißen bei der Familie
Gerz
z.B Katana Gerz und ihr Mann müssen
improvisieren weil die Kita schon wieder
zu hat ja klar schön ist das nicht aber
im Moment sehen wir das Positive mein
Mann und ich können Überstunden abfeiern
und es ist ja auch zusätzliche quality
time mit den Kindern
[Musik]
it K bitte einmal ganz al leg das wieder
zurü Mama sauer das
[Musik]
ipadita hat immer noch zu da gibt's
jetzt wohl leuse oder die Kera keine
Ahnung aber als Filialleiterin von dem
Baummarkt kann man halt nicht ewig frei
machen deswegen habe ich jetzt in der
Not die kleine einfach mal mit zur
Arbeit gebracht so Sophie du setzt dich
jetzt einfach so dahin und guck sein
Bilderbuch ja toll und die Mama kommt in
vier Stunden wieder was ist denn hier
[Musik]
los okay ja sie ist leider sehr unruhig
die kleine weil sie hochbegabt ist aber
ich habe jetzt eine Lösung um sie zu
beschäftigen ja was machst du eigentlich
hier win win sopel lern zahlen und ich
spar eine Fachkraft 3000 € bit
einfach Zahlen toll machst du das
wirklich katjanas Mann hat derweil den
gemeinsamen Sohn mit an seinen
Arbeitsplatz genommen in der Chirurgie
der Kölner Uniklinik so Alex jetzt
schauen wir mal zusammen wo bei dem
Onkel die galenblase sitz ja spannend
oder komm
oh an den Abenden versuchen die
erschöpften Eltern außerdem ihre Kinder
noch altersgerecht zu fördern Katze
genau sehr gut machst du das ich schaffe
das aber nicht bei beiden für mehr
reicht meine Energie einfach nicht da
muss man sich für ein Kind entscheiden
ist halt so eine wird gefördert und der
andere bleibt
doof ist nicht schlimm Alex du kannst ja
später eine reiche Frau heiraten h am
Ende des Tages bleiben dem Paar nur
wenige Stunden allein also eins ist klar
mit der Kita Situation auf keinen Fall
noch ein Kind und ich habe so Angst dass
ich mal die Pille vergesse deswegen muss
mein Mann jetzt immer super Hosen tragen
das ist Gift für die sper und wenn trotz
Erschöpfung und enger Hose überraschend
doch Erotik in der Luft liegt haben die
gzens inzwischen eine einfache
Lösung erinnern Sie sich auch frü habe
ich keinen Bock mehr ich auch
nicht die haben gesagt ich soll meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen das mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Chef besesos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonniere endlich den
verkackten heute sch Kanal also geht
doch